we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail commenting on on yesterday's
show I suggested that Venezuelan
president Nicolas Maduro might flee if
indeed he decides to flee he might flee
to Bolivia although it's unclear maybe
to Cuba although it's not clear Cuba
would want him because of what that
would mean for Cuba US relations
maybe the Nicaragua here's a caller who
suggested a different option for Nicolas
Maduro hi David
my name is Karla I'm calling in to to
discuss the video that you recently
uploaded about the Venezuelan president
Maduro and speculating as to where he
might plead should the military turn
against him and and I would swear that
she chimp in president of China is
backing him over the interim president
so so as a possible that he made clearly
China
what are you of course Thanks I don't
think so okay you know there are also
it's not just who would have him there's
also the question of cultural issues and
as someone myself who was born in
Argentina if I was presented with the
option of safe haven in another
spanish-speaking country like Nicaragua
or Cuba or Bolivia versus China even if
I thought maybe economically I would be
better off in China I don't know it
would be very difficult to imagine going
to a country where I don't speak the
language and I'm of a completely
different culture than another country
in Latin America so I don't see that as
particularly likely and quite frankly I
I would imagine Nicolas Maduro ends up
in Russia before I would imagine that he
ends up in China but the caller is not
wrong about the Chinese president's view
on what's going on in Venezuela we've
got a great bonus show for you today get
instant access to it by becoming a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
will talk about the sometimes taboo
topic of athletes who were
born biologically male participating in
female athletic competitions we will
talk about that and much more on today's
bonus show